okay hello everybody this is Peter
Cooper from the NCBI today's NCBI minute
is going to be on textbooks on the NCBI
bookshelf during the webinar if you have
a question please type it in the
questions pod
I will try to answer it unlike the one
I'm going to be presenting Rhonda Morris
will be presenting and so I'll try to
answer the questions and at the end will
people able to address some of them
orally and Stacey Lazarus here from
bookshelf to answer them for you if
there are questions that we don't get to
and all questions in fact are going to
be put into a document that's going to
be linked to our webinars in courses
page the slides and supplemental
materials and the QA documents are also
going to be on the FTP site and that
link there that compressed URL will take
you to the FTP site and I'm going to
turn it over now to random Morris who's
gonna be presenting thanks for joining
us today today we're gonna talk about
textbooks that are available on the NCBI
bookshelf and how they got there and
maybe how you can have your textbook on
the bookshelf as well since 1999 NCBI
has worked with publishers and authors
to provide an additional way for readers
to access their products the NCBI
bookshelf also called books for short
houses books reports documents and other
literature based media on life sciences
and health-related topics the specific
topics or the scope was selected by our
parent organization the US National
Library of Medicine the bookshelf
collects and makes available only
full-text works not abstracts for
example and they are all in English one
of the things that NCBI is known for are
links provided between related pieces of
information within and between resources
throughout NCBI we do this to provide a
way for users of our site to learn and
discover more about our topics of
interest since many of our databases
involve biological data it was natural
to consider providing links between our
databases and to biological and
health-related textbooks and other books
on the bookshelf these are a large
number of databases that we have in
various domain fields we have long been
known for our literature databases
particularly PubMed and more recently
PubMed Central
or pmc we've also maintained biological
sequence databases for nucleotides and
proteins since 1990 and have added other
sequence related databases as well as
those housing data related to genes
protein structure and activity and
chemicals and more recently have added
several health and clinically focused
databases to our suite of resources as
the years and scientific research has
progressed we're adding more and more
the NCBI bookshelf or books database is
another literature database which can
connect to all of these resources the
link to a lot of the basic science
information is perhaps one reason why
textbooks have been so successfully
added to and integrated within the NCBI
system
so why textbooks in fact the NCBI book
shell started in 1999 with a single book
in edition of one of the most respected
molecular biology textbooks to have been
published the third edition of molecular
biology of the cell by Bruce Albert's
Alexander Johnson Julian Lewis Martin
raff Keith Roberts and Peter Walter the
text was submitted to us for inclusion
in the NCBI bookshelf by garland
publishing with the blessing of the
author's recently we've caught up with
Bruce Alberts the lead author of this
esteemed book who relate to us that all
of the authors of the molecular biology
of the cell were pleased when garland
publishing decided to post the third
edition of our textbook on bookshelf and
we were especially happy that this free
resource has been heavily used
contributing to an important u.s. effort
to spread science to students across the
globe in addition to molecular biology
of the cell several other extremely
popular textbooks were added early on
including bird tomoko and dryers
biochemistry 5th edition
Barron's medical biochemistry 4th
edition and Walker Hall and Hearst
clinical methods 3rd edition all of
these are considered classic textbooks
which continue to be well regarded and
are still used today a quote from one
frequent user of these books a professor
teaching graduate and professional level
life science and clinical courses
mention that I grew up with Striders
biochemistry and Albert's molecular
biology of the cell all you'd need to
add is Lewin
jeans and I never leave my computer but
seriously I've recommended the NCBI
bookshelf to my students included links
to the textbooks in syllabi that
incorporated graphics and tables with
attribution in lectures for over 12
years now
having access to free high-quality
textbooks is key to being able to meet
the needs of my graduate medical and PA
students the online version of these
texts include all features of the
hardcopy books including graphics images
and tables which are some of the most
heavily viewed sections of these books
but some say these books are old are
they still useful are they still being
used in fact they are in January 2018
hundreds of thousands of people were
accessing and spending time looking
through and reading these textbooks
there are four these four that currently
the most popular and used entries on the
NCBI bookshelf ok so faculty who have
grown up with these classic texts may
feel comfortable with them but what
about students that are being newly
exposed to these disciplines and their
undergraduate studies why are they still
accessing these classic texts here's a
quote from an undergraduate biochemistry
major that's really representative of
what we've heard from students Shawn
says I can't afford to spend 350 to 400
dollars for a single textbook even if I
could carrying it around as a pain in
the neck literally being able to look
things up on my laptop or cell phone
anywhere my study group happens to be is
the only way I've gotten through my
biology courses and I'm like what's on
most of the web I know I can trust what
I find at the National Library of
Medicine the cost factor as well as the
platform for textbooks are both
important factors in student usage of
textbooks in a blog post on the Wiley
Network by the library director of the
Western University Western Michigan
University School of Medicine she
explored student preferences and
concluded that overall we know learners
sometimes prefer print other times they
prefer the electronic version but
generally surveys on the subject seem to
be an agreement that having access to
both an electronic and print textbook
copy is optimal at the NCBI bookshelf
we've had some new books textbooks added
to our inventory
in recent years and in fact one of them
the essentials of glycobiology was
unique in that it was conceived from the
outset by its editors publisher and NCBI
is a book that would be published
simultaneously in print by a Cold Spring
Harbor press and also made available in
full-text online at the NCBI bookshelf
the editors in the publisher hoped that
this would serve as a worldwide model
for an open education vision they
recently provided a quote to us we were
happy to have collaborated with NCBI
staff whose skills in efficiency ensured
our book would be discoverable and
freely accessible to researchers
instructors students and others after
simultaneous release and print and full
text online with online only updates
available on the inside NCBI bookshelf
we were very happy to work with Ajit
Varkey and John Inglis on this project
but why would other publishers want to
consider this type of model why would
publishers be interested in making
textbooks freely available for their
customers in a white paper published by
Springer Nature in November of 2017
called the oay effect how does open
access affect the use of scholarly books
they revealed that open access which go
even further than just free online
textbooks are downloaded seven times
more than any others in the first year
of publication are cited 50% more over
four years and are mentioned online 10
times more over three years essentially
there is a significant amount of free
advertisement and marketing that
organically grows from making books
freely available on the internet and
this dramatically increases the
potential and realized audience for
these books in a bought blog post
exploring the data in this white paper
books in the oay effect one publishers
perspective they mentioned that in
addition to free advertising and
expanded audience which benefitted the
publisher two other groups
seemed to strongly support this movement
for free online open access book
availability funders or sponsors were
motivated by specific ethical
considerations that publicly funded
research should be open for the public
to read they were also interested in
fulfilling their and their off
expectations for finding mechanisms to
reach a larger audience authors
motivations included improving access to
research information enhancing
dissemination to a wider broader
audience and also providing a way for
students to be impacted by their work at
low cost the links to both the
whitepaper and the blog are there on the
slide at NCBI we can help you do all of
this what the NCBI bookshop shelf can do
for you so here's what we hope to do
make your textbook findable and usable
for anyone anywhere it's on the Internet
optimize the indexing of your book in
Google and in PubMed to make it easy to
find enable viewing in any web browser
via scrolling web style pages and we
also have an ebook style pub reader that
often makes the books easier to read we
also hope to expand your audience to
more than just college classes who have
already adopted your textbook because
they can access it as well here's the
view of Katherine Jenkins who is the
open access books workflows coordinator
at the publisher Springer Nature who has
submitted many many books which are
available on the NCBI bookshelf the NCBI
bookshelf offers an additional route for
wider discoverability for our open
access books and welcome funded oay
chapters and helps to direct traffic
through these to the texts hosted on our
own platform springerlink
the HTML display on the device agnostic
platform is user friendly and renders
our books and easily navigable sections
to create a best-in-class
online reading experience we value our
collaboration so to summarize NCBI
bookshelf can increase the
discoverability of your text and provide
a link to help readers find your own
site and resources and where a good
collaborative partner who is able to
present your work online for a great
reader experience are you interested
what do you need to know about getting
your book on the NCBI bookshelf first
please keep in mind the scope of the
works as specified by the US National
Library of Medicine we take books about
life sciences and health-related topics
and they must be in English and need to
be in full text not just abstracts or
citations who can apply to have their
book included in the NCBI bookshelf the
applications to include the book must be
driven by the copyright holder of the
text however that copyright holder needs
to make sure that all participating
members of the team agree on the
submission including authors editors
publishers funders and/or sponsors so to
begin the application process you can
download an application from the NCBI
website there's also a new sub for new
submitters a publisher application form
as well to fill out once those are
filled out you can submit it to the
bookshelf by email which I will provide
shortly it is important also to provide
details of the work including the title
and an abstract for the book as well as
bios for the editor and authors and a
copy of the book for review for printed
books this should either be to hard
copies or an electronic PDF version of
the book for e-books you can send in
either the electronic files or the URL
for accessing these files actually if
you just go to the NCBI bookshelf home
page you can find links to all sorts of
helpful information including a whole
section for people who want to have
their books on the bookshelf including a
whole set of documents as to how to
apply there's also info for people who
want to learn how to use the bookshelf
including a quick start guide and FAQ is
that answer really common questions that
people want to know can I use figures
from the bookshelf how do I cite books
from the bookshelf can a publisher also
provide their work on other sites in
addition to the bookshelf
by the way hint hint the answers yes so
in conclusion we've got a couple of
direct URLs for you the NCBI bookshelves
home page that you just saw as well as
links to other helpful documentation
again these are linked directly on the
home page from the bookshelf so you can
start there here is the direct link for
the information for authors and
publishers and how to apply if you have
additional questions or in
you can reach the ncbi's bookshelf staff
directly at this email bookshelf at NCBI
NLM nih.gov and it's with all of our
NCBI minute webinars we'd like to finish
with a place that you can go to learn
more about any of our ncbi's various
resources the NCBI insights blog the
NCBI YouTube channel and for any
questions general questions about NCBI
you can always send it into the info at
NCBI NLM nih.gov address even for the
bookshelf you can send it there and we
can route it over to the bookshelf
people as well thank you for your
attention we now have some time for some
questions that you've written in the
chat pod and the head of the NCBI
bookshelf group Stacy Lathrop is here
and she can answer your pressing
question this is Peter Cooper again so
we have one question so far and this is
directed to Stacy I think would you be
interested in a previous edition of a
text if a new edition has already been
published hi thank you for your question
we do accept previous editions we do
prefer the most recent edition we have
some older edition so if it's not the
newest edition we will take say the next
second most recent one okay thanks okay
here's a question how many books are on
the NCBI bookshelf we now have over
6,000 books in the bookshelf I do not
have the exact number but I can provide
that and I could do a search so the
easiest way to see how many books we
have on bookshelf would be to go to our
browse titles page which I'm clicking on
here and some of our books appear in our
archive so they're not in our default
browse or search this is usually for
clinical content because we do also have
a lot of systematic reviews and clinical
guidelines where the currency is
important and for our agreements we do
not make these available by default so
the complete number
titles we have we now have 6042 titles
and we're pretty much adding between
five and 20 a week thanks Daisy
is there is another question is there an
iPad iPhone app for the bookshelf we do
not currently have an iPad or iPhone app
what we do have is we have what we call
a pub reader version which I can
actually show you here I'm just going to
click this is actually a report rather
than a textbook but it will show you
what we have if you click on views to
pub reader it's an html5 page you can't
you can do a find within the book but
you can't search across the resource the
view looks differently obviously on a PC
or it is kind of device smart so if
you're on an iPad you can it will look
pretty similar to this and then on the
iPhone it doesn't scroll by page it will
just scroll down the page though it's a
little bit different on the iPhone which
I can't show you unfortunately
okay thanks okay I think this will be
the last question and this is construed
ins download the ebooks whether or not
students can download the ebooks is
dependent on the agreement that we have
with the publisher so if the publisher
agrees to participate in our open access
subset which some publishers have then
you can go to our FTP and download the
entire XML files and the also whether or
not you can download the pdf version of
the book is also dependent on the
agreement many do provide us to provide
the PDFs but not all of them so really
this is dependent on our agreements with
the publisher so let me show you a book
where we have permission to download the
P
yes I'm not going to choose a textbook
well here let me do this one the
handbook of a health evaluation is a
handbook so I'm going to move back to
the well you can see it here you have a
PDF so you can download the PDF to read
while you're not connected and you can
also switch to the classic you and I can
show you where it is in the classic view
again here you have the PD PDF version
for download I can show you where the
open access subset is so that you can
look where to find that so you would go
to our open access subset and then you
would go to NLM Lit arc FTP service
which is a number of clicks and you go
here and I'm gonna go to last modified
so there there's an excel file that
shows all of the content that we have
available for download so these are all
the book titles and it shows you the
file directory that by which you can
download the content okay thanks Stacy
and everyone for coming on let's go
ahead and conclude the webinar and we'll
see you next time thanks for coming
you